all right so this is the tar
you hear that
do you hear that did it did it
and sometimes just
that's what you should hear
not
not that
so
this is really good all right
so it could be a lot worse but if you go
there so when you've got the taranuchi
so if you put your kenneth when you've
got the taranucci
you should look at your ken
and as you cut it down because it's
rubber
it might jump
to the left
it might jump to the right so these are
all things that if you've got a
tabernucci or you try at any stage these
are things you'll see or you'll get
you'll get this
the thing to do is
you sense you said you squeeze it like
like ringing water out of a towel
at the very end so you go
squeeze
you then
have a little injection going forward
all right so you don't just
cut it down
but you
squeeze you feel the difference in the
all right so if you just go down
as that
if you go forward
it's that
has more power in going forward because
it becomes like a slice
all right so it mustn't go to the left
it mustn't go to the right
it mustn't
bounce
i used to have a
a young student 19 years of age
he used to hit the tar and keep in it
and you could see the tar sort of feed
most people that hit the target sort of
like took them back
so that what you then take from it is
you now use the bounce from the tyre
and this is really what we've been
talking about this morning in aikido we
used like i was timing with the partner
when i hit that
i'm going to use the energy
to get the ken up there
if i go like that and now mechanically
do this
this is what i call basic school
you feel the difference in the power
so
you have to work out
are you out of breath
you know did you put everything into the
cat
or
or can you use the power that the first
one gave you so the taranuchi is not
just the tile that you whack away
thinking it's going to make your hips
strong
and then somebody asked me about in the
31 carter 5 6 7 8.
if i take this energy
and you can do in the 31 carter
without going like this
seven
eight
you know one's mechanical physical the
other one is energized
and then you you start learning
hypogeary different directions
because
you know i was talking about sensing
spiritual and that
you're in a dimension where time
isn't
thought of or time
is
kind of about isn't available
all right so you do the footwork
and then you just do it and of course i
ain't got time to talk have i ain't got
time to think
it's uh so
but i'm
i'm working on
oh the bounce i'm working on my oh
so i'm having to demonstrate by
pretending the bounce is there so i'm
putting the bounce in
but really the bounce is uh
created by the taranuchi
all right so i hope i've given you a bit
of an insight in that
sorry
hey
when you do that if you're too focused
on just the cut
you'll be stuck here
if you're
thinking of the taranuchi
you can keep flowering
okay thank you
does anybody have any questions while
you're there not about that about
anything you know
roses pruning roses or
but um perhaps you didn't know about
that you know perhaps you didn't know
about the tavonucci
just when you were earlier when you were
talking about the uh sensing
what are your thoughts on the breathing
during the um
[Music]
yeah that's a good question isn't it
is our breathing
correct or not what the biggest problem
is we don't realize when we're holding
our breath
what a big problem i've got with uh
iwama students is they go
hey
i'm going why are they key on ah
it's a little bit like saying i need
that coal shoveling over here so you go
over there and you go oh go get the
shovel alumni it's like i need the
breath
what what's the oh sense the um
what's the oh scentsy videos
hey ah
you know you need the breath
to do the technique
now come on
if i key eye afterwards
sorry
hey hey
this is not so i don't know why they do
it they all say to me or we would talk
that anyone when i go
yeah i don't like it i've always been a
rebel i always
been an individual if i'm going to be
hey
that's when i need the breath
when i need it
why would i
look you can do without breath
you can do it without breath but then
that's you're going into mind power
you're going into telepathy
you're going into mind power
why is he falling down he doesn't know
what i'm doing is i'm i've already
focused on him like i'll focus on you so
if i focus on you but i can still focus
on him so now i've got two i've got
focus i focus on jenny so now i've got
three i can focus on dominique so i've
got four
so you're all now plugged in to me
so when he cut i'll try and explain this
when he comes i don't just softly go
over here and go
oh
nothing happening if i go
i had to get in his head
and sense
him
it's almost like i had to go
well this is just this is just my this
is just my hand you know
but if i go with my mind
it's almost like you're pushing air
that's the only way i could describe it
to you it's like i'm pushing air and if
you do this with your hands you can
actually feel what i mean about
condensing air
so you know you can try it by all means
you know i don't always talk about this
stuff sometimes i do but if you can feel
this condensing of air between your two
hands
is it condensing air or is it condensing
your energy
so when i do this it's a measured point
over him
and
it's a measured point i mustn't go
further
or else
the space will be too great
too complicated really isn't it
but uh
yeah
that's when when you say i said you say
how are you going to learn that you've
got to watch osensee and you've got to
try and get inside him you're watching a
film and you'll go what's he doing now
is it how is he how's that sense he'd
been how to do that throw them down now
how's that sense he's been able to go
how can he control that how can he get
them
how can he make that per you know this
big strong man how can he make him just
fall down like that the physical side
we got connection but mentally
mentally here look
so that's
mental and physical
so what i've done over the years i've
tried to get inside what i think i sense
is doing and then i've thought about ah
but he used to sit a lot and do
meditation didn't he
and i don't believe in religion so i'm
not going to go down that track but i'm
going to try and do as many things as he
done so he would sit and i know that as
we all sit if you just sit there and go
what am i supposed to think about
you're thinking too hard if you go
i just got to breathe out and try and
think of nothing
oh i think something's coming in now
thank you i just want to be
think of nothing
that space
is what i obtain before i do what i just
shown you
i have a space i've i obtain a space of
nothingness
only calmness and peace
when you do that correctly you're more
powerful than ever
all right so you see it as an action
but it can be a
there's this one
you take it
and you add
okay
so i know that answered your question as
long as long answer wasn't it
so what i'm doing is perhaps different
to what you're doing
but if you do the mechanical things
follow your own beliefs
follow your own paths
at the end of it well hopefully it's not
my end yet but when you get down the end
of my line you'll know whether it your
path worked out right or not
you can't you know i don't believe in
all that crap you know if that's where
you want to believe don't want to
believe in it you might be better i
could earn anybody